imaginemos como solemos hacer en
economía un mundo muy sencillo en el que
hay dos países que pueden producir ya
sea pantalones o camisas o alguna
combinación de los dos aquí tenemos las
curvas de posibilidades de producción de
cada país la curva por trabajador y la
curva por día si el país a pone toda su
energía en los pantalones puede producir
20 si la pone en las camisas puede
producir 10 también podría producir
alguna combinación que se colocaría en
esta línea para ayudarnos a asimilar las
curvas de posibilidades de producción de
ambos países vamos a elaborar una tabla
de producción esta columna será la
producción del país
y esta será la producción del país ve
pensemos en la producción potencial de
pantalones por trabajador y por día el
trabajador por día es el insumo luego
pensemos en la producción potencial de
camisas cuál es el máximo de pantalones
y camisas en los países de pausa en el
vídeo y traten de resolverlo en el país
ya lo hemos mencionado el máximo de
pantalones es 20 y el máximo de camisas
sí no
ningún pantalón es 10 en el país ve el
máximo de pantalones es 30 y el máximo
de camisas es 45 ahora bien ya sea a
partir de estas curvas de posibilidades
de producción o de esta tabla de
producción podemos calcular los costos
de oportunidad el costo de oportunidad
es constante por lo que las curvas de
posibilidades de producción son líneas
rectas con pendiente fija este es el
país
y este es el país ve vamos a calcular el
costo de oportunidad de los pantalones y
luego el de las camisas pause nuevamente
el vídeo y traten de calcularlo una
manera de plantearnos este problema es
si el país a pone toda su energía en los
pantalones produce 20 si pone toda su
energía en las camisas produce 10 separa
camisas ve para pantalones si queremos
hallar el costo de los pantalones
podemos dividir ambos lados de esta
ecuación entre 20 para obtener el costo
de oportunidad por pantalón el cual es
igual a 10 dividido entre 20 que es
igual a media camisa entonces la energía
necesaria para producir un pantalón es
la misma que la energía
área para producir media camisa así que
podríamos decir que el costo de
oportunidad de producir un pantalón es
media camisa
si queremos hallar el costo de
oportunidad de las camisas podemos tomar
el recíproco de este número que es 2
entre un pantalón o podemos calcularlo
con esta ecuación y en vez de resolver p
resolvemos cuánta energía en términos de
pantalones necesitaremos para producir
una camisa si dividimos ambos lados de
esta ecuación entre 10 obtendremos que 2
p es igual a una c si lo planteamos de
otra manera la energía necesaria para
producir una camisa es igual a la
energía que se necesita para producir
dos pantalones el costo de oportunidad
de producir una camisa es los pantalones
porque con la misma energía que se
necesita para una camisa podríamos
producir dos pantalones utilizamos el
mismo método para calcular los costos de
oportunidad de los pantalones y las
camisas en el país bebé si el país me
pone toda su energía en los pantalones
produce 30 si la pone en las camisas
produce 45 entonces el costo de
oportunidad de cada pan
si dividimos ambos lados entre 30 será
45 entre 30 lo que equivale a 3 medios
de una camisa así pues la energía
necesaria para producir un pantalón es
igual a la energía que se necesita para
producir una y media camisas entonces el
costo de oportunidad de los pantalones
es que por cada pantalón el país ve deja
de producir una y media camisas para el
costo de oportunidad de las camisas si
dividimos ambos lados entre 45 obtenemos
que la misma energía que se necesita
para producir una camisa produciría 30 a
45 a bosch de un pantalón que es lo
mismo que dos tercios de un pantalón una
vez dados los costos de oportunidad en
que debería enfocarse cada país pausa en
el vídeo y traten de averiguarlo primero
vamos a comparar los costos de
oportunidad de los pantalones queda
claro que el país
tiene un costo de oportunidad más bajo
en la producción de pantalones sólo deja
de producir media camisa mientras que el
país ve deja de producir una y media
camisas entonces el país
tiene la ventaja comparativa en
pantalones
de acuerdo con la teoría de la ventaja
comparativa debería enfocar toda su
producción en los pantalones del mismo
modo si vemos el costo de oportunidad de
las camisas el país ve solo deja de
producir dos tercios de un pantalón
mientras que el país
dejaría de producir dos pantalones
entonces el país ve tiene el costo de
oportunidad más bajo y por tanto la
ventaja comparativa en camisas por lo
que debería enfocarse en la producción
de ellas pero se lo que deben estar
pensando la gente no puede andar por ahí
usando solo camisas podrían sentir frío
debajo de la cintura o la gente no
quiere usar solo pantalones podrían
sentir frío arriba de la cintura
entonces cómo puede la gente de los
países ahí ve obtener el otro tipo de
prenda la respuesta es obvia si enfocan
su producción de esta manera pueden
comerciar y cuál sería un precio
comercial aceptable para digamos los
pantalones concentrémonos en los
pantalones por un momento vamos a pensar
en el mercado de pantalones si fuéramos
el país
por cuánto estaríamos dispuestos a
vender pantalones en términos de camisas
precio sería una cantidad mayor que
nuestro costo de oportunidad entonces a
está dispuesto a vender pantalones a un
precio lo voy a poner entre comillas
porque en realidad estamos pensando en
el precio en términos de otro bien a un
precio mayor que su costo de oportunidad
que es media camisa también está entre
comillas la disposición a vender en
nuestro lenguaje cotidiano en realidad
aquí se está comerciando del mismo modo
el país ve está dispuesto a comprar
pantalones su gente necesita pantalones
de lo contrario andaría por ahí solo en
camisa y el país ve está dispuesto a
comprarlos a un precio menor que a su
costo de oportunidad de pantalones que
es de 1.5 camisas entonces cuál sería un
precio razonable que sea mayor a media
camisa y menor a una y media camisas en
realidad cualquier precio entre estos
los parámetros funcionaría pero sólo
para redondear un buen precio para el
comercio entre los dos países sería de
un pantalón por una camisa ahora
tratemos de entender las ganancias que
se obtienen del comercio de ambos países
imaginemos este mundo
del país a produce 20 pantalones por
trabajador y por día pero supongamos que
decide que quiere comerciar 15 de esos
20 pantalones por camisas a este precio
obtiene 15 camisas renuncia a 15
pantalones y se queda con 5 pero obtiene
15 camisas entonces va a terminar en
este punto lo fantástico de esto es que
ahora está más allá de su curva de
posibilidades de producción aquí podemos
ver muy claramente la ganancia del
comercio porque el país
no habría podido llegar a este punto por
sí solo del mismo modo el país ve estaba
en este punto con 45 camisas renunció a
15 de ellas y ahora tiene 30 camisas
pero también tiene 15 pantalones por lo
menos algunas de las personas en este
país ahora van a poder usar pantalones
entonces el país ve tiene 15 pantalones
y también está en un punto por encima de
su curva de posibilidades de producción
no podría haber llegado aquí sin el
comercio así que ambos países están
mejor y el punto clave de este vídeo es
que ahora entendemos por qué la ventaja
comparativa es valiosa si tomamos todas
las suposiciones para estos modelos
simplificados porque podemos calcular el
costo de oportunidad a partir de la
ventaja comparativa y luego podemos
pensar en un buen precio al cual los dos
países están dispuestos a comerciar y
ver que cuando comercian ambos son
capaces de rebasar sus curvas de
posibilidades de producción nos vemos en
el siguiente vídeo